hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
chapter 3 of John Rawls a theory of
justice is entitled interestingly enough
the main idea of the theory of justice
and as it turns out he's going to
introduce several main ideas there that
are all connected together but one of
the most important starting points is
what he's going to call the initial
condition or original position and it's
often talked about as a veil of
ignorance because Rawls in fact used
that term and we're going to talk about
what we're ignorant of in this but first
we should think about what why is Rawls
bringing this up in the first place
his theory of justice and of ethics more
broadly speaking is going to rely on an
idea of social contract but one that's a
bit different than his predecessors and
we'll talk about how the original
position is different than the old state
of nature that Hobbes or Locke or
Rousseau brought up in the past this is
a hypothetical condition just as those
were but it's a somewhat different one
he says that
we are going to decide in advance how to
regulate claims against one another and
what is going to be the foundation
charter of our society as we're engaging
in this thought process and he says just
as each person must decide by rational
reflection what constitutes very good so
at an individual level that is the
system of ends which it's rational for
that person to pursue so a group of
persons must decide once and for all
what's going to count among them as just
and unjust
right or wrong and here there's a you
know difference being made between the
good and the right which we don't to
worry about too much but it's worth
signaling so we have individual
conceptions of the good and individual
pursuits of that perhaps done with other
people as well and then there's a
broader conception which involves other
people necessarily and that is that of
justice and injustice now
Rawls tells us that the choice which
rational people would make in this
hypothetical situation of equal liberty
equal freedom assuming for the present
that the choice problem has a solution
which he does think is the case
determines the principle of justice
principles rather and so he says
injustice is fairness which is his view
the original position of equality
corresponds to the state of nature and
the traditional theory the social
contract but there's some differences
here and he says that we're going to
choose behind a veil of ignorance which
we'll look at in just a moment he also
tells us that in engaging in this this
choice what we're doing is choosing the
first principles of our conception of
justice so we're choosing how society
ought to be ordered in the very broad
sense and we're choosing principles that
will be used to criticize and correct
any sorts of empirical that is exist
staying deviations from this and this is
going to lead ultimately for Rawls the
way that he thinks it's gonna go to a
sort of you know broadly welfare
liberalism that's going to have a strong
safety net for for individuals and going
to have certain basic principles it's
also given a lot of room for individual
freedoms and for you know various things
like redressing things that have gone
wrong you know procedures for addressing
problems so choosing these first
principles of a conception of justice
turns out to be incredibly important and
that's what the original condition he
thinks is going to allow us in part
because he says the parties to this
another big assumption of course is very
hypothetical our rational and mutually
disinterested that is they are following
a certain as we is going to call it
narrow economic conception of
rationality which we'll look at in just
a moment and they don't already have
relationships with each other that lead
them to take each other into account so
let's talk now about this veil of
ignorance because this is probably the
most distinctive part of of this and he
says this is different than the state of
nature as conceived of in the
traditional theory of the social
contract why it's not an actual
historical state of affairs some
versions of social contract theory think
that people actually did in fact get
together at some time and and you know
say we need to organize the society and
you know decide on some really basic
principles there's a lot of criticisms
of that point of view as a historically
existing construct it's very difficult
to find any history of that and if we
want to sort of hypothetically extend
that back into the past we're really
stretching hume pointed out some
problems with this that we don't have to
go into here but it's also been thought
of as a sort of primitive condition
nature and he says it's understood
instead is a purely hypothetical
situation characterized so as to lead to
a certain conception of justice and you
can say well okay you know walk Hobbes
they don't actually necessarily commit
themselves to there being this this
perfect state of nature they have
hypothetical constructs as well don't
they well let's assume that they do for
the moment they do but they assume that
it's already existing human beings who
know something about themselves and know
something about the way the world works
and how who they are would affect that
and likewise be affected by that in
relation to others Rawls says no no we
leave all of that aside we are entering
into what he calls the veil of ignorance
we don't know a whole bunch of important
things so we don't know for example
nobody knows their place in society
their class position or social status
that's a game changer so if you are
well-off and you're creating this new
society you don't know where you're
going to end up as a matter of fact if
you create a society that has incredible
inequality of wealth or status or
opportunity or other things and the
majority of the population are in the
lower strata there's a very good chance
you would wind up in that lower strata
so it would be irrational for you to
decide that in those circumstances if
you know that well there's a good chance
you'll wind up in the top part even
though most other people wind up in the
lower part because you happen to have
gone to Harvard or you happen to you
know have illustrious ancestors or pick
whatever other distinctive you want well
then you're no longer behind the veil of
ignorance are you you have already
figured out the rules of the economic
social political cultural system this is
saying you don't actually know
what imagine it's sort of like being in
a role-playing game you have no idea
what your randomly generated character
is going to be as far as where you're
coming from and your social status or
anything along those lines who your
parents were
he also says nobody knows their fortune
in the distribution of natural assets
and abilities
what are those that's that's kind of a
interest in jargon they're natural
assets and abilities intelligence you
don't know whether you're going to be
particularly smart or what areas you're
going to be intelligent in some people
are naturally good communicators other
people are terrible at it right some
people can learn over time to go from
being bad communicators to good
communicators being able to learn is
itself part of intelligence some people
you really can't teach them much of
anything there's all kinds of
intelligence right there's the abilities
to you know identify abstract patterns
and you know carry out all sorts of
interesting calculations and things like
that and all the things we tend to
associate over here with that Q I know
there's more involved in IQ than just
that but then there's you know we talk
about emotional intelligence and we talk
about other things you don't have any
idea where you're gonna end up in that
you might be a really great communicator
right now with the person who you are
you might be tongue-tied in every
circumstance and we don't know also
about strength or our bodies could be
that you are going to be born with some
sort of congenital defect that will
shorten your life or cause you pain day
after day after day or just hinder you
in certain ways or it could be that
you're going to be given all sorts of
really great advantages as well you
simply don't know he goes on a little
bit further he says I'll even assume the
parties do not know
there are conceptions of the good or
there's special psychological propensity
'z what do they mean by that
so conceptions of the good well we can
think of all sorts of traditional
conceptions of the good in ancient
philosophy some people think for example
like Plato that it's harmonizing these
different parts of yourself so being a
well integrated person who's effectively
ruled by rationality and Keith can keep
their appetites more or less within
certain bounds and develop the virtues
and all of that Aristotle says something
kind of similar but talks about virtuous
activity along with friendships a
relationships and a certain amount of
wealth Stoics said virtue is the only
thing that really counts
you know the epicurean said it was
pleasure and a lack of pain these are
all traditional conceptions and we might
think about today you know how people
frame success or celebrity or all sorts
of other things along those lines you
don't know what you're going to value as
the good you don't know ahead of time
what sort of lives you would view as
good lives and what sort of lives you
would view as bad lives what sort of
lives would be flourishing what sort of
lives would be corrupted or defective in
any way you don't know that we also
don't know as he calls it's special
psychological propensity 'he's you don't
know for example when it comes to
sexuality who or what you're going to be
attracted to what sort of acts you would
enjoy what sort of things you would find
repugnant you don't know what sort of
foods you're going to be interested in
or if you care about food at all or if
you're gonna be a wine enthusiast you
don't know what sort of music you're
going to want to listen to you don't
know any of these things you don't know
whether you're an introvert or an
extrovert you don't know any of these
psychological features of yourself now
this takes quite a lot of work to to
bring about doesn't it imagine stripping
all of these attributes
away from yourself you you wouldn't be
you anymore now in the lottery of the
society that you're going into you could
wind up being you and that would be just
fine or you could wind up being somebody
who has one quality different from
yourself or you could wind up being
somebody totally different you don't
know what ethnicity or race you will be
classified as if race even matters you
won't know what gender you're going to
be you won't know when you're going to
be born you won't know any of these
sorts of things behind the veil of
ignorance so if that's the case he says
what is this going to produce he says no
one is advantaged or disadvantaged in
the choice of principles by the outcome
of natural chance or the contingency of
social circumstances because we're all
similarly situated and nobody is able to
design principles to favor his
particular condition the principles of
justice are the result of a fair
argument or bargain he calls this
asymmetry of everyone's relations to
each other and he says that this is
going to produce for us an actual just
society a blueprint for it at least so
you know this is this is actually we're
thinking about nobody is able to design
principles to favor his particular
condition why is he so focused on that
because there is a tendency when we're
engaging in social engineering to be
unfair with respect to that this is a
big problem when it comes to systemic
issues for example those of race or
gender or social class it's very easy
for people who are in a privileged
position to downplay the importance of
things that act as impediments to other
people or as detriments we could come up
with example after example after example
of unfairness
of this sort stretching back through you
know the through the 21st and into the
the 20th century and we probably would
never finish accumulating those examples
so the initial condition is supposed to
get us to a point where we can move away
from those sorts of issues now he says
that one feature of Justices fairness is
to think of the parties in the initial
situation as rational and mutually
disinterested what what does that mean
he says that it doesn't mean that the
parties are egoists that is individuals
with only certain kinds of interests in
wealth prestige domination and those
sorts of things but they're conceived as
not taking an interest in another's
interests they are to presume that even
their spiritual aims may be opposed in
the way that aims of those of different
religions may be opposed so we're not
enemies to each other we're not in a
zero-sum game but we can't count on
identifying with other people's
interests or them identifying with our
own so if we want there to be a space
for something that we think we might
actually find important we have to
create the space for that and in doing
so we created for others who might end
up involved in that conception of the
good what does it mean to be rational
here he says that rationality must be
interpreted as far as possible in the
narrow sense standard in economic theory
of taking the most effective means to
given ends I'll modify this concept he
says later but we have to try to avoid
introducing into it any controversial
ethical elements and what is what does
that mean so we want to think of people
as having certain given ends that we all
share in common maybe broadly speaking
you know things like not being sick and
being able to exercise a degree of
agency but we can't build into it any
robust
substantive conceptions
rationality going beyond this because if
we do again we're no longer within the
original position and we're kind of
playing favorites the last thing that I
want to say about this is we can carry
out this this thought experiment on our
own we can think okay so I don't know
where I'm gonna end up in this society
what kind of society would I make mmm I
might be male or female or non-binary I
might be attracted to you know one
gender or another maybe I'm not
interested in sex at all maybe I want to
have sex with anything that moves what
kind of foods do I want to eat oh I
might have a food allergy hmm what if I
have this what if that leads me to other
things what if I have this disease or
this disease or this disease Oh what if
I can't enjoy certain things and I enjoy
other things in ways that other people
find repugnant what how how should I
arrange society we can carry it all this
out on our own we can say what kind of
profession would I have should I be a
woodcutter or a record spinner or maybe
learn to code and oh but maybe that's
not gonna be around that that far down
the line maybe I should be a librarian
maybe I should be a teacher maybe I
should be a homecare nurse we don't know
where we're going to end up and we're
doing this by ourself right so there's a
dialectical process going on in our head
and then we think about well what kind
of society would I need to make so that
I don't end up on the short end of the
stick and when I end up being a
african-american female home health care
nurse living in a rough part of town
that doesn't have good access to public
transportation and is in a food desert
oh maybe I shouldn't maybe I shouldn't
make the society discriminate against
people like that in that condition I can
do this on my own but Rawls actually in
this this hypothetical thought
experiment intends that we would be
doing it with other
so we would enter into it we try to go
into this veil of ignorance as best as
we can and then we'd see what other
people have to say and the assumption
here is that we are rational but we're
not robots we're not all exactly the
same and so we have to have some sort of
discussion with others a little bit
earlier he talked about it as involving
a kind of bargaining right or a sort of
fair agreement that we would be engaged
with with other people and a little bit
later he says that yeah we would want to
be engaging with others so that they can
bring up things that were missing out on
and he notes too that we're not going to
necessarily get everything that we would
want for ourselves in the exact people
that we are but that's part of the point
of going behind the veil of ignorance so
it's it's taking into stock the possible
conditions and outcomes for people
across the board and abstracting away
from the concrete existing individuals
who we are this is the beginning point
for his theory of justice
you